can the disney princesses be even more  fabulous  it turns out they can when they get  transformed into today's biggest celebs  if you've ever wondered what these  ladies would look like if they rocked a  pop career  wonder no more artist lisa volkova  matches up disney royalty with our  favorite fierce females  join us as we watch this talented artist  work her magic with modern day makeovers  worthy  of the met ball  [Music]  do  [Music]  me  [Music]  is  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  just imagine all these popular  princesses forming a girl group  they'd make quite the squad which  transformation is your favorite  be sure to tell us in the comments  section and please hit that subscribe  button while you're here  thanks for watching  [Music]